Joe and I met in 1966 when we began our
intern
ships at the Massachusetts General
Hospital in internal medicine I had been
a medical student at the University of
Pennsylvania the nation's oldest medical
school and Joe had been a had graduated
from Southwestern Medical College in
Dallas Texas the nation's youngest
medical school that I had never heard of
I thought it was a Bible School but
within two days after we began our
internship we realized that we had
something in common we were both
interested in the fundamental basis of
disease not only in taking care of our
patients which was our first
responsibility but also trying to figure
out why this person had a heart attack
why this person had rheumatoid arthritis
why did this person have pneumonia and
it was that interest in the basis of
disease that created this friendship
that is now lasted since 1966 after our
residency's we went to the National
Institutes of Health where both of us
worked in with very exceptional
scientists Jo with Marshall nirenberg
and I with Earl Staten and two of the
best most brilliant scientists at NIH
but we also had clinical duties and
there we saw a patient that actually
determined the scientific course of the
rest of our lives so the patient that
Mike and I saw at the NIH was a little
girl the first patient with the disease
called familial hypercholesterolemia
also called homozygous familial
hypercholesterolemia rfh and her brother
actually had the same disorder and this
little girl has a very high cholesterol
her cholesterol is as high as 800 to 900
milligrams per deciliter the normal of
child of this age would be about a 120
milligrams per deciliter and most of
this high cholesterol was in a
lipoprotein called LDL which is known to
everyone is the bad form of cholesterol
and when LD
accumulates in the blood as in this
little girl
it deposits in the skin in these little
yellow lumps you see on the surface of
our skin that call xanthomas and it also
accumulates in the artery wall and
produces coronary heart disease and this
little girl had a heart attack
when she was 6 years of age now this
little girl had only elevated LDL she
had no high blood pressure she had no
diabetes she didn't smoke she didn't
have a Type A personality her only risk
factor for having a heart attack at age
6 was this high level of LDL so this is
one of the best examples of a disease
where we really know the cause and the
cause of the disease and this old girl
as I say increased level of her LDL and
so it would be important to understand
the basis of why her LDL is elevated and
also how it causes her disease
this is LDL the lipoprotein that build
up in the plasma of this young girl it's
a spherical particle with it it's about
the size of a small virus and each LDL
particle has 1,500 molecules of
cholesterol within its core and it's
surrounded by a polar coat of
phospholipid and a protein called a PO B
and LDL circulates in the blood on
average for about three days in humans
and eventually it leaves the blood
stream when we began our work no one
knew anything about what controlled the
level of LDL in the blood we were
interested in this disease because not
only did the homozygotes have problems
but the heterozygotes people who inherit
one copy of the abnormal gene have a
moderately elevated cholesterol and they
have heart attacks not at age six but at
age 60 and so if you ignore the
homozygotes the heterozygotes trance
with their disease in an autosomal
dominant fashion through the the
pedigree and so having a single copy of
the mutant gene no matter what it is
produced a disease now at the time there
were about 35 single gene diseases that
had been worked out and that the
defective gene product was known all 35
of those were enzymes mutations in
enzymes and all of them were autosomal
recessive that means that the
heterozygote had no symptoms but in in
the case of familial
hypercholesterolemia the heterozygote
had a disease and we thought that if we
could understand this disease it would
be the first dominant disease that could
be elucidated in humans and it might
teach us something about proteins that
are that are not enzymes we assume that
it was not going to be an enzyme and
that it would probably be some disorder
of regulation now Joe had promised his
professor at Southwestern Medical
College that he would return there after
his training and Joe and I talked about
this and Joe and we decided that I would
also go to Dallas and we went and when
we went to Dallas we would both try to
figure out what type of defect could
cause this high LDL level and the unique
approach that we took was to study the
metabolism of cholesterol in cultured
cells we obtained biopsies from children
with familial hypercholesterolemia and
compared them with normal cells and
studied the regulation of cholesterol
synthesis because we thought that this
would be some regulatory abnormality so
here's an experiment that Mike and I
carried out in 1973 and it's arguably
probably the most exciting experiment
that we've ever done and it really
hooked us on science and also taught us
a lesson that I'll come back to after
describing the experiment and so as Mike
pointed out we wanted to understand
what there was about the regulation and
cholesterol synthesis in in these
children with homozygous FH it was
different from normal and so at the time
it was known from studies in rats and
mice that when you fed one of these
small animals cholesterol you would
suppress cholesterol synthesis in the
liver there was a hint that there was a
regulatory system level and that the
liver was was known to be the most
important organ in the body for
controlling cholesterol but there was no
way that we could get liver biopsies
from patients so we chose fibroblast
which one could get skin fibroblasts and
this was sort of a heretical idea at the
time the one would study a fundamental
process that was going on in the liver
in a fiberglass but we did it anyway and
here's the experiment and the first
experiment we did worked and it was
really quite dramatic so what we did is
to to compare fibroblast grown in fetal
calf serum which contains LDL from a
normal subject and one of these children
with homozygous familial
hypercholesterolemia and you can see in
the red curve on the on the left that
the level of the cholesterol synthesis
was very low almost undetectable now as
a as a surrogate for cholesterol
synthesis we use the enzyme hmg-coa
reductase which had been known from
these animal studies to be a key rate
controlling enzyme in the cholesterol
biosynthetic pathway so we were able to
set up a assay for this enzyme and we
would have to incubating the cells with
this fetal calf serum that contained LDL
we would make extracts and do the
measurement so you can see that at zero
time the in the red curve the level was
very low and then when we removed the
serum and the LDL from the medial the
next 24 hours the enzyme activity in the
normal cells in red went up 50 to 104
and then when we only in the right panel
when we remove when we added LDL back
you can see that that very high level of
the enzyme h mg k co a reductase came
down to the the basal level when the LDL
was added back so this is a this in
itself was a very interesting experiment
in the normal because they told us that
there was a an effect of LDL cholesterol
and regulating the activity of this
enzyme that reflected the cholesterol
biosynthetic pathway and normals but the
that in itself was exciting but the real
dramatic result was when this result and
the normal was compared to the fh
homozygote shown in yellow and you can
see that at zero time and the presence
of a fetal calf serum and LDL the level
of the enzyme HMG co-reductase and
cholesterol synthesis was a hundred
times higher than in the normal and and
it didn't change no matter what we did
when when removed the LDL a stayed high
and when added LDL back it stayed high
so this was really dramatic it was
really all and now that was one of the
things that I think not only was it an
exciting result but it it sort of
addicted us to the fact that that we
were really interested in all future
experiments and seeing big changes we
don't usually see changes of a
hundredfold but at least it told us that
one had to have really a big change to
really work out something now the
simplest interpretation from this result
when Mike and I sat down and tried to to
deal with it after 24 hours of being all
on the wall and off the wall of
excitement we decided that the
simplistic interpretation was that the
fh homozygote cells had a mutation in
their enzyme HMG co-reductase
they rendered the enzyme resistant to
feedback regulation by cholesterol so we
said okay well if that's true then we
should be able to add cholesterol not in
LDL but in ethanol and we would get the
same result but then when we
did that the curve the yellow curve in
the fh homozygote was he came down from
this hundred fold just like the normal
and so the normal and the fh homozygote
elves are now responding to cholesterol
and ethanol
where's the fh homozygote did not
respond to the to the LDL so that then
told us that our original hypothesis was
wrong and now we have a new hypothesis
that said that the defect in the fh
homozygote was a failure to extract the
cholesterol from LDL so how does a
normal sell this now became the question
how does a normal cell extract the
cholesterol from LDL so we radio labeled
LDL with ID and 125 and incubated it
with the fibroblast and what we saw was
that when we incubated the L do with
normal fiberglass there was high
affinity cell surface binding that was
saturable is shown by the red line on
this slide but when we incubated the LDL
with the fh homozygote fibroblast there
was no binding so the problem was in the
end that there must have been a receptor
on the cell surface that binds LDL and
the fh homozygote cells lack this
receptor now this was 1974 it was in the
very very early days receptors were kind
of theoretical concepts how they worked
was there was very little known about
how they actually worked but we went one
step further when we incubated the cells
with I 125 LDL we followed what happened
to the LDL after the binding reaction
and we were shocked to find that the I
125 LDL was totally degraded the protein
was degraded down to amino acids and the
only way that could happen would be if
the LDL had been taken into the cell and
degraded in the digestive organelle of
the cell which is the lysosome so once
we knew that there was a putative
receptor on the
surface of the cells we advanced the
concept of an LDL receptor pathway in
which LDL bound to receptors on the cell
surface in specialized regions call Cody
pits and and our colleague and
collaborator Richard Anderson was able
to demonstrate by electron microscopy
the localization of a farad and labeled
LDL in these coated pits Cody pits
occupy only about 2% of the cell surface
of a fibroblast and and so it's a very
specialized region for rapid into
cytosis and internalization of of
proteins like LDL
so once the LDL bound to Cody pit the
Cody pits pinched soft foam Cody
vesicles which delivered the LDL to
induce ohms and then ultimately the
lysosomes where the LDL was degraded and
the cholesterol was released and that
cholesterol was in we used by the self a
membrane synthesis so we now knew from
the LDL receptor pathway that that in
addition to this to obtaining
cholesterol from cholesterol synthesis
cells could also obtain a pain
cholesterol through the receptor
mediated endocytosis of LDL in this
cholesterol and not only was used for
the synthesis of plasma membranes but
also it exerted a feedback regulation on
on the enzymes involved in the
cholesterol biosynthetic pathway and it
also exerted a feedback suppression on
the gene for the LDL receptor someone
had a coordinate a feedback regulatory
system based on both entry from LDL and
a biosynthesis so what happened in the
fh homozygote selves the lacked LDL
receptor how did they obtain their
cholesterol for membrane synthesis and
maintain cholesterol homeostasis so in
these cells they relaxed
virtually completely on the cholesterol
biosynthetic pathway and and that is
their source of
cholesterol and butt though so the cell
is happy because the cell has its
cholesterol for its membrane synthesis
but it's all at the expense of an
elevated LDL in the bloodstream which is
the root of this disease familial
hypercholesterolemia when the LDL builds
up and ultimately deposits in the skin
for these anthems and in the artery wall
to produce atherosclerosis so over the
next few years we were able to define in
detail the pathway by which LDL delivers
the cholesterol to cells and it's shown
on this slide
after binding to the receptor encoded
pits the LDL is internalized and it's
delivered to light to endosomes and
within endosomes there are proton pumps
that acidify the interior of the
endosome that causes a conformational
change in the receptor so that it
releases the LDL particle the LDL is
then carried further into lysosomes
where it's totally degraded and the
cholesterol is liberated for use in to
make new membranes LDL derived
cholesterol is also used for steroid
hormones bile acids it's used to make
new lipoproteins and it as Joe mentioned
it exerts regulatory actions so that LDL
derived cholesterol is really important
biologically after the LDL dissociates
from the receptor the receptor returns
to the cell surface in a recycling
endosome and each of these each LDL
receptor makes one trip into and out of
the cell every 20 minutes and it makes
hundreds of trips during its lifetime
and each time it carries an LDL particle
with 1,500 molecules of cholesterol
ester we gave this process its general
name which is receptor mediated
endocytosis and after we had described
the system for LDL it turned out that
other scientists found that other
proteins bound to their own receptors on
the surface but they were taken in and
into the cell in the same way
as LDL and the examples include hormones
such as insulin transport proteins such
as transferrin which transports iron and
vitamin and the protein that transports
vitamin b12 so receptor mediated
endocytosis turned out to be a general
property of all cells at least all
nucleated cells and it's interesting
that we had no idea that we would
stumble into something that was so
general as all we wanted to do is figure
out what was wrong with these children
with FH so you know this slide shows
what we look like when we started and
what we look like now I think it's
important for any young people looking
at this video not to picture us the way
we are now as shown on the right but
picture us as we were in 1972 when I was
31 years old and Joe was 32 years old
that's when we made these big
discoveries and and the thrill of
discovery when you're young and working
hard and something happens like that FH
experiment that Joe described the thrill
of that is amazing and I want to say one
other thing that it's a fantastic thing
to share that experience with somebody
else we've we have the longest running
partnership and we think in the history
of science to be honest and and I I just
have a hard time understanding why
somebody would want to do science
totally on their own without somebody to
share the adventure you you wouldn't
want to take a trip to Paris by yourself
would you I mean you you want somebody
along who can share the excitement of
that adventure and that and that's what
Joe and I have had so it's been it's a
fantastic thing to have a partnership in
science
you